well donald trump threatened to do it it
was sort of confusing
why he was threatening to do it but he
did it donald trump has vetoed the
second coronavirus relief package that
got through the house and senate
and now there are immediately a number
of important things here and let me get
to what for many people
is the most pressing and important
question does this mean
that if you were expecting a six hundred
dollar check
uh if you make up to seventy five
thousand dollars a year that you will
not be getting your six hundred dollars
and the answer is we can't say that yet
because this may be
the first time that during donald
trump's presidency the house and senate
are going to override
donald trump's veto remember that uh
if a president vetoes a bill passed by
the house and senate the house and
senate can override that with a
two-thirds vote
in the house and a two-thirds vote in
the senate and that may well
happen reports are that the house will
vote
on monday and if the house votes to
override the senate will reconvene on
tuesday to vote as well now the
explanation for why
trump vetoed this bill is actually sort
of incoherent donald trump with his veto
notice saying quote my administration
has taken strong actions to help
keep our nation safe and support our
service members
i will not approve this bill which would
put the interests of the washington dc
establishment over
those of the american people now what
trump
seems to be referring to here is what he
mentioned on tuesday in that very
strange speech he gave where
he listed countries and other
environmental and and other causes
that were receiving money but they were
actually receiving the money from the
spending bill not the covet bill but
they were passed
together reminder of that from donald
trump's tuesday video
this bill contains 85.5 million dollars
for assistance to
cambodia 134 million dollars to burma
1.3 billion dollars for egypt
and the egyptian military which will go
out and buy almost exclusively
russian military equipment 25 million
dollars for
democracy and gender programs in
pakistan
505 million dollars to belize costa rica
el salvador guatemala
honduras nicaragua and panama
40 million dollars for the kennedy
center in washington d.c
which is not even open for business one
billion dollars for the smithsonian
and an additional 154 million dollars
for the national gallery of art
likewise these facilities are
essentially
not open seven million dollars for reef
fish
management 25 billion dollars to combat
asian carp 2.5 million dollars to count
the number of amberjack fish
in the gulf of mexico a provision to
promote
the breeding of fish in federal
hatcheries
three million dollars in poultry
production technology
two million dollars to research the
impact of downed trees
566 million dollars for construction
projects
at the fbi so there are about three to
four ways in which this is incoherent
first of all
the money trump is talking about is in
the spending bill
to keep government open which was passed
alongside
the covet bill as an omnibus bill so
it is true that these things were voted
on together it is not true that the
covet bill
includes the things that donald trump is
mentioning but then adding as a next
layer to this incoherence
uh the spending bill which trump is
referencing
contains basically the same or less
money
than what trump asked for in his own
budget just some months ago trump asked
for the money in the spending bill
that he now vetoed which is not actually
part of the coveted bill
they were simply put together for a vote
which i'm against doing to be clear
uh trump also said 600 isn't enough and
he wants two thousand dollars during
that tuesday speech
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the ridiculously low
six hundred dollars to two thousand
dollars
or four thousand dollars for a couple
i'm also asking congress to immediately
get rid of the wasteful and unnecessary
items
from this legislation so once again i
agree with trump
but many democrats have been talking
about two thousand dollars
since may and it's been trump's
republican party that's been against
more money now trump says he wants more
well it would have been nice for him to
push for that
and lobby for that in may when some
democrats
wanted it but republicans by and large
don't but don't want more money
it's just up and down erratic one way
one way or the other and then of course
deep down
there may be other reasons not being
mentioned for donald trump's veto one is
that the spending bill
doesn't eliminate section 230 trump has
been obsessed with this section 230
says that if people post things that are
legally problematic to twitter
the people are responsible or liable not
twitter if people do the same thing with
youtube or facebook
it's the users not the platform
responsible trump believes
that if you get rid of section 230 and
make the platforms legally responsible
lots of anti-trump stuff would be taken
down
trump's just wrong about that he just
misunderstands and then trump also
is essentially defunding the troops in
vetoing this bill
while he claims to be the biggest
supporter who has funded them more than
anybody else
ever has and then lastly it also appears
trump didn't like some of the anti-money
laundering provisions that are in
the spending bill not the covid bill and
we recently learned
that jared kushner has been running a
shell company to siphon campaign
donations off
and pay salaries to trump's own family
members and friends so
there's incoherence there's likely a
self-serving aspect
there's really a little bit of
everything here in the end
the mediocre bill will probably pass as
the house and senate is expected
to override trump's veto next week again
if all goes
as it is expected to go what if you
could read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls and kieran rogers
and so useful so particularly applicable
to what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about eight bucks
a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video